brailling 12-month revenue they're
saying ltm in their s1 is the document
you file when you're growing pod their
ltm or trailing 12-month revenue is 487
million which is 33 year-over-year
revenue companies that grow over 20
percent are considered high growth in
the public markets in the private
markets maybe not so much and in this
case this means warby parker's revenue
from june 2020 to june 2021 basically
half a billion dollars so in our
industry you'll hear the term annual
reoccurring revenue ar that's typically
for sas businesses that means the
revenue is guaranteed to keep going that
doesn't apply when you're selling
glasses it's not like people are having
a subscription to classes and maybe they
do have a subscription process in which
case they could say annual recurring
revenue ltm
is
the last 12 months and people could say
trailing 12 months so that just gives
you an idea of what you know is actually
going on with the business a little more
i would say honest intellectually honest
so when i meet with founders i just
always ask them the same thing what are
the last three months and then i'll put
in parentheses three numbers just so
we're clear i'm not looking for one
number i'm not looking for three
paragraphs i'm not looking for
disclaimers and man my job is maddening
sometimes i will ask a founder for the
last three months revenue and they will
start talking for 10 minutes i still
don't have the numbers it is bonkers if
you are working with investors or
potential investors and they ask you a
really simple question give them the
answer because they probably have a
follow-up question and the follow-up
question might be really good for you to
give so the first half of 2021 puts them
at a 540 million runway they did 270
million that's pretty great they claim
to have a 60 gross margin that's nice
they operate 145 stores and claim to
have over 2 million active customers not
sure how they define active customers we
talked about that on previous episodes
what's an active customer for me an
active customer would be somebody who
made a purchase in the last 12 months
like a fair one to me
because they might come back
we talked about next door
saying people who open an email were
active users
this is one of those things if you're
going to be a public market investor
you're going to want to really drill
into
oh actually my research has just told me
active customers that are unique
customers that have made at least one
purchase of any product or service in
the proceeding 12 months i had literally
guessed it that's good in 2019 warby
parker essentially broke even in 2020
they lost about 56 million which is
nothing losing a little bit of money
while you're growing a business it's
called investing in the business
in 2021 they're on pace to lose about
14.5 million so they're decreasing the
loss or they're investing less there'll
be two different ways to look at it
depending on if you're a growth investor
or you want to see profits one of the
most money losing slash break even
businesses of all time was
amazon
and now they've turned on the
profitability just by turning a dial
they can just decide how much money they
want to make
by increasing the cost of amazon prime i
don't know if parker has that ability i
don't know what percentage of market
share they have if they made every pair
of glasses 25 more and increase their
profitability
would they lose customers where people
push out buying new glasses ecommerce is
hard all right so just taking a pause
here i have invested in d2c companies
before most of the time we say no to
these companies 99 times out of 100 and
a lot of investors hate this specific
sector why do they hate it it's because
if you're warby parker and you're one of
the greatest d2c companies of all time
along with dollar shave club and many
others
direct to consumer is low margin and
hard to scale
and if they're only making 30
year-over-year growth right at warby
parker and they're making nine figures
let's compare that to a software
business like twilio well twilio
has a 2.4 billion dollar 2021 uh run
rate that's up 65 year over year and
they're at a 63 billion dollar market
cap and twilio has two times warby
parker's growth rate with four times the
revenue why is this one of them selling
software one of them is consumption
based right and the other one is selling
a physical product selling physical
product hard to scale uh warby parker is
also not a marketplace it was a
marketplace and you had a bunch of
sellers on one side and you had a bunch
of buyers and warby parker was managing
that and taking a rake a percentage of
the sales like ebay does or uber does or
any number airbnb of marketplaces that
might be higher scale that might be more
interesting so investors love software
and marketplaces
they love consumer subscriptions they
love fintech they hate direct to
consumer it's a really hard business you
need to have a very new product say
eight sleep which is a direct consumer
business we've invested in or tara cafe
which is a very unique
direct-to-consumer business in my mind
and i don't mind investing in them but i
do when i look at those businesses look
at them differently than consumer
subscription sas and marketplaces let's
take
an incredible example youtube 28 billion
dollar run rate for 2021 83 euro for
your growth
youtube is not a spring chicken the they
have three times warby parker's growth
rate with 50 times their revenue so take
a pause and ask yourself if you're
placing a bet are you going to place a
bet on warby parker yeah i wouldn't it
doesn't seem like a high growth business
to me and finally amazon web servers is
a 56 billion dollar run rate for 2021.
what's their growth rate 30
in other words
amazon web services with 56 billion
dollars in revenue that is not a small
company that is a huge company they've
got the same growth rate as warby parker
is this the fault of management at warby
parker no it's just the nature of
different businesses have different
margins
and different growth rates it's very
hard
for
a company that makes a physical product
to scale sas software yeah that scales
so one final thought here about warby
parker cnn business reporter nathaniel
meyerson dug up a pretty interesting
insight from the s1 where they talked
about the positive trend and signals for
their business staring at your computer
all day is good for webby parker the
rising usage of smartphones tablets
computers and other devices has
contributed significantly to increased
vision correction needs and consistent
new customer growth within the eyewear
market in other words we're all going
blind
from staring at our smartphones i don't
i know it i started wearing this past
year like readers if anybody has
suggestions for me about how to get my
eyesight back do i have to stop looking
at screens should i get lasik i don't
know i've never had eye problems i gotta
figure this out so you're all going uh
blind and warby parker's gonna win maybe
i should invest before we get into the
ad let me just tell you straight up
linkedin.com twist your first job
posting free i'm not kidding
linkedin.com twist your first job
listing free nothing to lose okay now on
to the end too many small business
owners are busier than ever they spend
time searching for and interviewing the
wrong candidates for a job opening and
it would be much better for them to
spend their time growing their business
that's why linkedin jobs has made it
easier to get the candidates worth
interviewing faster and that's why
they're giving you the first job listing
for free at linkedin.comtwist
they know it's gonna work here's how it
works you create a free post in minutes
on linkedin jobs and you reach the
world's largest professional network
with over 750 million people i remember
reading this ad when it was like 150
million my god they're growing it's like
one of the biggest growth stories inside
of microsoft in fact so they focus on
candidates with the skills and
experience that you need and you can use
screening questions to get your role in
front of the most qualified people we
love linkedin jobs at launch and in 2021
we've hired a third producer a
curriculum designer for founder
university and two more researchers and
we're still hiring for three more
positions using
you guessed it linkedin jobs so linkedin
jobs will help you find the candidates
that are worth interviewing faster every
week nearly 40 million job seekers visit
linkedin so post your job for free at
linkedin.com twist terms and conditions
apply because they're giving you
something for free